in the lobby of Ramsey solutions Bart
and Felicia are with us hey guys how are
you
where are you better than I deserve good
to have you guys where do you live
Chicago Valerie Oh fun good to have you
very cool so uh how much debt have you
two paid off so we paid off eighty one
thousand dollars over the last four
years Wow very cool okay and making what
kind of range of income during that time
I'm so from four years ago call it 140
this year thank God around two hundred
thousand good for you guys what do you
two do what do you two do for a living
I'm in procurement mm-hmm and I'm gonna
guess very cool good for you guys fun so
what kind of debt was the eighty one
thousand so the ID one thousand was a
combination of both car and student
loans and a couple of credit cards big
student loans then B cars how much did
you owe on the cars so the timeline is
kind of fragmented
so because I actually started the
program first and I got rid of my dad
was around thirty three thousand and the
back half of forty eight thousand was uh
hers about half of it is cars and other
half student loans so you guys got
married in this process that is Western
ah we just got married in July oh wow
well congratulations thank you so since
July what have you all done since July
it was around twenty nine thousand
dollars Wow my six well since it's
obvious so called it's six months okay
so Felicia it sounds like mr. Bart is
he's like on this get out of debt plan
he's mister budget Bart right
and you're dating him and he goes okay
we got to talk
yeah he goes what to do a budget how do
you spell that did not want to do a
budget so I was the spouse that wouldn't
get on board I got you okay
before the probably before you were a
spouse even right before I was out while
you're dating you're talking but it's
made it even worse
yeah that's us puts everything on pins
and needles for sure okay and so how
much did you own your car Felicia
yeah about 20,000 because I bought the
car like right before we took fvu yeah
okay all right well that's what people
do they go out they go out and have
dessert right before they go on a diet
right tell me he told me not to do it
but it was before FPU Dave Ramsey's
gonna heck we're never gonna get too hot
to eat again and so I'm gonna go deeply
in debt here and yeah yeah yeah Oh fun
so you guys went through Financial Peace
University while you were dating then
yes okay
that's correct the winter of 2013 okay
so all kidding aside that had to cause
some conflict I don't know any other way
to say it I mean you guys are talking
about this stuff and it's like you know
she bought this car right beforehand and
and you've been getting out of debt and
then she starts to go I got to do this
too and it starts to make sense I mean
there had to be some really kind of
tense conversations in the dating FPU
type stuff going on was there yeah I
think before we actually took FPU it was
very tense that's why I suggested that
we take it together and I think that was
actually the turning point once we both
want the same page okay all right
Felicia I you're getting ready say I was
just gonna say that when we took FPU it
didn't really hit me into everyone was
going around saying why they were there
and everyone was talking about their
debt and then it hit me that he didn't
have any debt so I was like we're here
for me Felicia and I am here because
the class changed my life I tell
everybody the class definitely changed
my life and I definitely know that we
won't be one of those people getting a
divorce over money because of FB you
know so I'm very grateful they think
I've made it thank you that's very very
cool well congratulations
that is very neat well it is a very good
pre-marriage counseling tool and to go
through the class together and because
it is such a touchy point in marriage
this whole handling of money thing so
then you get married and mr. budget Bart
and you are now on the attack plan on
this debt of yours and twenty nine
thousand bucks since you since you
walked down the aisle that's pretty
strong yes what was the hardest part of
that year honestly since we've been
married it wasn't that tough I mean we
already took fvu we already were both on
the same page and pretty focused about
what the goal was and we thought it
would take us till about mid year but
thank God we just we were able to knock
it out in February so she just come you
just combined incomes and go game on
here we go yeah and I mean we were still
doing budgets together even though
things were separate before we were
married because of FPU so cool it wasn't
too difficult I loved it that is awesome
which church did you take the class in
are we actually took it at a local
insurance company um but we this year
gonna start teaching it out at our
church insights hurting us okay Illinois
Oh very neat good well thank you for
doing that
very cool well you guys are awesome
you're obviously rock stars I'm here you
stand you know how old are you I'm 28
years old and I'm 28 she turns 14 I did
married an older woman like Adam you
guys are fun well I mean here you stand
28 years old you're making a couple
hundred thousand dollars a year you're
obviously rock stars and your careers
congratulations and you know bad you
know payments how does that feel it
feels great I'm so excited I would have
never thought I would be the one to be
so excited about this but I was the one
I was like we have to do a debt-free
screen
if I'm going through all this we're
going to Nashville yeah love it alright
Bart and Felicia's Chicago Illinois
$81,000 paid off twenty nine since the
marriage last summer all total in four
years making 140 to 200 through that
time counted down
let's hear a debt free scream three -
why thank you
all right congratulations you two
that is how it's done right there oh
just like that hey you guys Rachael Cruz
here hope you are enjoying the Dave
Ramsey show and did you know that I have
my very own YouTube channel yes that's
right it's kind of better than the Dave
Ramsey channel don't tell them I said
that I'm kidding I'm kidding
so subscribe and there's lots of videos
about life and money so while you're at
it if you want to check out a video then
you can check out how to do a monthly
budget it's one of the best videos out
there
you